cet après-midi un discours de volodimir
Zelenski devant le Sénat américain
bonjour Nicolas tener merci de répondre
à FRANCE 24 vous êtes politologue
enseignant à Sciences Po et spécialiste
des questions stratégiques et
internationales vous êtes également
directeur de publication de desk Russie
la Maison Blanche on l' bien compris
pousse à un accord au Congrès avec à la
clé 60 milliards de dollars d'aide à
l'Ukraine vous direz que c'est l'avenir
de la guerre qui est en jeu là
oui absolument parce que il est clair
que kif a absolument besoin d'armes
massives elle a a besoin de plus de à
longue portée notamment elle a besoin de
tank elle a besoin de munition elle
aurait aussi besoin évidemment d'avion
de chasse que les États-Unis ne
donneront pas directement même s'ils ont
accepté de fournir des pièces de
rechange pour les F1 qui seront fournis
par d'autres pays qui en sont les
possesseurs euh mais c'est vraiment
quelque chose de d'immédiat c'est-à-dire
que ce n'est pas une question de de
voilà de de quelques mois c'est c'est
aujourd'hui évidemment que kif a besoin
de ses armes d'ailleurs on parlait tout
à l'heure de les échec relatif de la
contreoffensive de l'Ukraine en fait
elle était dû déjà au manque d'armement
suffisant fourni par les Occidentaux et
là-dessus il y a malgré
effectivementstruction d'un certain
nombre de républicains à la chambre et
surtout d'ailleurs à la la la maison des
représentants c'est surtout duû je
dirais au fait que les américains
notamment et les alliés n'ont pas donné
d'assz d'armes c'est-à-dire que les
fautes aussi sont du côté de
l'administration américaine actuelle ne
l'oublions pas l'aide allemande aussi
est capital elle est pour l'instant
suspendue puisque l'Allemagne a un trou
dans son budget 60 milliards d'euros
après la la décision de la Cour
constitutionnel c'est une inquiétude de
plus ça pour les Ukrainiens
oui parce que l'Allemagne même s'il ne
donne pas des missiles à longue portée
taorus que l'Ukraine réclame parce que
là-dessus Scholz bloque complètement est
quand même l'un des principaux
pourvoyeurs européens d'aide militaire à
l'Ukraine et ça c'est également
totalement décisif parce que il y a
aussi des batteries de de d'air de de
missile anti-aérien et donc ça c'est
très important pour contrer les attaques
russes mais également des chars on sait
que les chars léopards notamment n'ont
pas été fournis en nombre suffisant en
tout cas le nombre escompté qui avait
été prévu et tout ceci est totalement
déterminant aujourd'hui les Américains
rappelons-le Nicolas Tenzer ont alloué
111 milliards de dollars à l'Ukraine
depuis le début de la guerre et ce qui
bloque en fait c'est la droite et
l'extrême droite américaine ils surfent
sur une certaine lasstitude qui est en
train de gagner les opinions publiques
aux États-Unis mais aussi en Europe
alors je pense qu'il y a il y a deux
choses il y a une première chose la
lassitudes des opinions publiques en
fait quand on regarde les différents
sondages c'est vrai aux États-Unis mais
c'est vrai également en France ou dans
d'autres pays on s'aperçoit soutient à
l'Ukraine et la perception du danger
russe reste très majoritaire
indépendamment des catégories des
affiliations politiques ça c'est très
important en revanche il y a un jeu d'un
certain nombre de républicains euh à la
Chambre des
Représentants c'est vrai des trumpistes
en particulier parce que tous les
républicains ne sont pas sur cette ligne
qui essaye de blo aussi des
compromissions d'une partie de cette
droite républicaine avec la Russie c'est
un phénomène inquiétant en revanche il y
a aussi des républicains qui ne sont pas
dans le camp de Trump et notamment au
Sénat auquel le président Zelenski va
s'adresser aujourd'hui qui sont très
favorables au maintien de l'aide à
l'Ukraine je pense en particulier à
Mitch McConnel qui est vraiment le l'un
des des des héros en quelque sorte je
dirais de de la la droite républicaine
non trumpiste qui dit il faut aller
beaucoup plus loin et ça je crois que
c'est aussi très important on a vraiment
une minorité voyez c'est une minorité de
blocage qui est capable vraiment de de
de faire dérailler cette aide qui est
aujourdis totalement vitale mais
néanmoins Nicolas Tenzer un retour
potentiel de Donald Trump en 2024 à la
tête des États-Unis ça serait une
bénédiction pour Poutine
oui ou bien sûr parce que on se doute
que Donald Trump qui a montré quand même
un certain nombre de signes disons
d'allégence même au kremelin n'a qu'une
seule idée c'est d'arrêter la guerre
c'est non seulement sa politique
d'America first mais également on sait
très bien on l'a vu qu'il y a des
complaisances très forte envers le
régime russe et là ça voudrait dire que
l'Ukraine ne serait pas capable de se
défendre parce que malheureusement c'est
aussi une autre réalité
l' même si elle accroit sa production
autant qu'elle le peut n'est pas en
mesure de remplacer les États-Unis les
États-Unis représentent plus de la
moitié des armes qui ont été alloué
jusqu'à présent à l'Ukraine donc
l'Europe fait de son mieux mais n'est
pas aujourd'hui capable encore une fois
de remplacer des États-Unis si ceuxci
venait à être défaillant et on a bien
compris que l'argent était le ner de la
guerre les Ukrainiens sont totalement
dépendants des aides américaines et
européennes la Russie est entrée en
économie de guerre dès le début du
conflit pas l'Europe pas les Américains
on on n'a pas pris la la mesure de la
situation je crois qu'on n' pas pris la
mesure de la situation rappelez-vous
Emmanuel Macron c'était au salon
d'armement euros satori en juin 2022
disait il faut que l'Union européenne
passe en économie de guerre alors c'est
vrai que du côté français un certain
nombre d'industriels notamment Nexter
qui ont triplé leur production
notamment César on le sait
particulièrement utile d'autres
industriels également l'ont fait mais il
faudrait aller beaucoup plus loin
c'estàdire que l'économie de guerre ça
veut dire aussi être capable de
réquisitionner un certain nombre
d'industries qui travaillent pour le
secteur civiles et de les transformer en
usine fabriquant de l'armement ça
suppose la réquisition et la formation
bien sûr d'un certain nombre de
personnes la Russie l'a fait en
particulier grâce au contournement de
sanctions par un certain nombre de pays
euh malheureusement l'Europe et les
États-Unis ne l'ont pas fait et on est
vraiment extrêmement loin du compte
merci merci beaucoup Nicolas Tenzer pour
vos explications sur France 24